we are live with the cast of Super
Troopers - let's bring it back at - you
know it's a free yeah so this is this
convention I feel like it's made for you
guys because your movie is really all
about the fans I mean how's it been for
you so far it's been great I mean we we
crowdfunded the movie so it was it very
much of a fan thing we made the movie
with the fans
and these are the events that it's fun
to come out and hang out with the fans
and they help make the movie so it's a
great thing 55,000 people gave us my own
yeah Wow when we raise 4.6 million
dollars so you guys were on the Conn
floor I think you guys did a signing
earlier did some stuff so how was it in
there did you see some Super Troopers
cosplay going on the weirdest thing was
like kind of being in the backstage area
and we saw Darth Vader with his mask off
making out with the Princess Leia that
was kinds of problems with well super
troopers - I love the movie it's out of
the way right now right yeah you guys
got so many great celeb kind of cameos
going on there actually just rolls Rob
Lowe and of course the Fred Savage and
incident how'd you guys get them
involved where they like jumping on
board immediately
well I directed Rob and Fred in their
show the grinder which was on Fox
canceled unfortunately but uh we had a
good time with a great time and I asked
Rob if he wanted a part in Super
Troopers 2 and he said yes anything I'll
do anything
and in Fred it was sitting right there
and he goes what about me I love that
you know when you say he would do
anything he did anything in that yeah we
still have good he's all gorgeous
sometime I'd already did like a looking
guy yeah
stunning I'm sure you guys have been
asking or people have been asking you
guys about a sequel since like the day
after the first one came out so why was
now the right time to do it I don't know
I think it was it had gotten to his
groundswell of people really wanted to
see it and you know it was on again off
again for a while here and there but I
think it was the fans that really pushed
it and and it was this crowdfunding
thing that really made
but now I think you know yeah we want to
make some other films we did a club beer
fest slammin salmon in-between it should
try some other plot some other
characters and then we want to put the
ray-bans on and grow the mustaches again
yeah like a lot of times when these you
know sequels along like a lot of time
passes be more like the how is it
getting all back together but you guys
have just been friends this entire time
yes annoyingly
this close to each other for 30 years we
we travel and sleep hotel room so I'm
standing back here is the worst did did
starting to write the sequel do not
spider into more ideas for more Super
Troopers movies yeah we're writing Super
Troopers 3 winter soldiers right now Wow
Winter Soldier I just can't wait for
infinity war on the road yeah yeah
that's spoilers spoilers by the way this
is like I have not been able to stop
singing Super Trouper by ABBA
yeah yeah does that is that like stuck
in your head forever cuz I was like
interviewing a Super Trouper casters
come in mama 3 I love it I don't know so
I'm sure a lot of people have also asked
Beerfest would you guys ever want to do
a sequel for that you guys working on
that where we're starting to sort of
kick around an idea for that one so
we're gonna make that I'm gonna make it
okay yeah if you say it'll happen
okay I'm saying you know as a fan it's
all about the the fans are gonna make it
happen
so there you go Super Troopers has so
many like iconic lines what is the one
that people say to you most when they
see on the street for me they call I can
I can swear they call me chicken lover
ahahaha chicken lover who wants a
mustache rise everyone people for me
always want to chug maple syrup mmm
yeah they come at me with
Mabel sir and then you're like wow and
then you're like absolutely a runaway
yeah like whenever you do interviews are
people like oh I got you some I post all
the time I have a whole refrigerator for
leaders of Cola for Kevin there we go
leaders Cola mm-hmm mm-hmm
I get you boys like Mexico a lot
shadowed me from passing cars yeah
probably a lot of people inserting meow
into like every conversation
lots and lots of be honest by the way
loved the Jim Gaffigan thing coming back
make it that was the one moment I was
like man I hope we full-circle this you
know he's that guy so big right now he
know he could get him what did think we
can get that guy right here like an hour
window and then he came back and he did
it well since you guys are our close
buds whose most like we're gonna do a
little most like I tell you again most
likely to be napping on set mmm napping
on set so does a cat most likely to
break laughs on set I did that on Beer
Fest I ruined to take spit into the beer
splash my face and then there at I had
to go get a blow dryer I ruin that yeah
most likely to actually break something
on the set is that me by the Bulge
mmm-hmm I guess me I'll be known to
break a chair maybe like sitting Mike's
ball be some exercise on top to exercise
ball Wow
once he popped next first of all and
then while he was telling the story of
that popping that exercise ball he
popped another exercise ball yeah do you
think there's these good pop what's the
crack the toilet seat gents crack toilet
seats yeah steel
okay most likely to prank someone on set
yeah mr. Brown clown we call him the
brown claw
unless he's mad that we call him the
brown frown all right well I think since
we are like headlining you guys are my
headline Comic Con anyway we have to
have a little toast you're starting to
get in this photo booth we're gonna have
a little fun thank you guys so much for
watching we're gonna go have a little
toast
[Music]